تستمر حركه طالبان الافغانيه باثاره الراي
العام المحلي والدولي ضدها بقرارات مجحفه
مستهدفه النساء الافغانيات في تعليمهن
ورزقهن ولا يبدو انها تنوي التوقف فبعد
قرار حرمان النساء من التعليم الى اجل غير
مسمى اصدرت الحركه المتشدده قرارا اخر
يقضي بايقاف عمل الموظفات في جميع
المنظمات غير الحكوميه في افغانستان
القرار الجديد اصدرته وزاره الاقتصاد
تابعه لطالبان مرجعه اياه الى شكاوى جديه
وردتها بشان عدم الامتثال للحجاب اضافه
الى غير ذلك من القواعد واللوائح المتعلقه
بعمل المراه في المنظمات المحليه والدوليه
واضافت الوزاره في رساله واجهتها الى
المنظمات غير الحكوميه الدوليه والمحليه
انه في حاله اهمال التوجيه يلغى ترخيص
ولم يتضح حتى الان ما اذا كانت هذه
التوجيهات ستؤثر على العاملات الاجنبيات
في المنظمات غير الحكوميه ام ان ذلك سيطل
فقط الافغانيات من هنا واشتكى مسؤولون في
منظمات دوليه تشارك في العمل الانساني في
مناطق نائيه من افغانستان من القرار وقال
احدهم ان لدى منظم طه عدد كبير من
الموظفات لمعالجه المخاوف ان لديه عددا
كبيرا اذا من الموظفات المعالجه المخاوف
المتعلقه منها بالمساعدات الانسانيه
للنساء الافغانيهات وتسائل كيف نعالج
مخاوفهن الان الامر لم يتوقفون هنا اذ
اعلنت اربع منظمات اضافيه اجنبيه تعليق
عملياتها في افغانستان بعد قرار طالبان من
بينها منظمات انقذوا الاطفال والمجلس
النرويجيين ومنظمه كير لجنه الانقاذ
الدولي
المنظمات وهذا قالت انها لا تستطيع الوصول
بشكل فعال الى الاطفال والنساء والرجال
الذين هم في مس الحاجه الى المساعده في
افغانستان من دون موظفاتهم قررت طالبان
اثار غضبا دوليا كبيرا اذ حذر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني من ان القرار
سيعطل تسليم المساعدات وقد يكون مدمرا على
افغانستان كتب لينكن على تويتر اشعر بقلق
عميق من ان حضره طالبان مساهمه النساء في
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في افغانستان
سيؤدي الى تعطيل المساعدات الحيويه
والمنقذه لحياه الملايين في مقابله مع
العربيه فكر مستشار احد منظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه بافغانستان حمزه حكيمي ان خروج
المؤسسات الاغاثيه الاجنبيه من افغانستان
يقبل الحكومه العاجزه عن حل الازمه الحج
بالطريقه الحاله المسؤوليه على عاتق
الحكومه على عاتق الجماعه التي تدير
الحكومه الان وتعتبر نفسها بانها الحكومه
تشكل الحكومه في افغانستان لكن همم بوجود
المؤسسات الاجنبيه والاضافيه الاجنبيه في
افغانستان الحكومه غير قادره على تقديم
هذه الخدمات فبعد المغادره هذه المؤسسات
من افغانستان بكل تاكيد ستتفاقم الازمه
بشكل كبير وسيزيد الضغط على اعتق الحكومه
التي هي اصل عاجزه عن تقديم الخدمات للشعب
الخدمات في مختلف القطاعات التي تغطيها
هذه المنظمات الاغاثيه همم البديل لابد
على الحكومه ان تقدم بديلا وهي اصلا عاجزه
عن تقديم البديل لكن همم على اي حال
الضحيه همم ستكون شعبا الافغاني الذي يعيش
اكثر من
79% من هذا الشعب تحت خط الفقر وهي شعب
المحتوى وهو شعب محتاج جدا لهذه همم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاضافيه بدورها
غردت منظمه العفو الدوليه قائله ان الحظر
محاوله مؤسفه لاقصاء المراه من المجالات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه في
افغانستان بينما افادت لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه بان موظفاتها في افغانستان
اللواتي يتجاوز عددهن 3000 امراه اساسيات
لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه في البلاد
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي يعد من ابرز الجهات
المموله للمنظمات الاغاثيه العامله في
افغانستان رغم عدم اعترافه بحكومه طالبان
رسميا دان القرار واكد انه يقيم تاثيره
على تقديم الاتحاد للمساعدات ميدانيا في
معتبر الصليب الاحمر ان قرار طالبان
استبعاد النساء في افغانستان من التعليم
ومن ادوارهم الانسانيه انه قد يؤدي الى
عواقب كارثيه ياتي هذا الاعلان بعد اربعه
ايام فقط من قرار حكومه طالبان منع
الافرانيات من الالتحاق بالجامعه العامه
والخاصه الى اجل غير مسمى والذي مرره وزير
التعليم العالي ندى محمد نادين بعدم
التزام الطالبات التعليميه بشان او
تعليمات عدم التزامهن التعليمات بشان
الحجاب
[موسيقى]